[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a grandi là ça va être détruit la
bâtiment là et un autre va tellement
votre côté donc trois bâtiments ça va
être détruit donc récemment sont en
train de vider les zapartistes reste pas
beaucoup d'habitants mustapha en est la
preuve
comme les autres il a dû quitter ses
barres d'immeubles prochainement
détruite
il a laissé le deux pièces très abîmées
dans lequel il vivait depuis une dizaine
d'années pour un p4 tout neuf après
trois ans d'attenté
il n'y croyait plus voilà une bonne
nouvelle
vous allez avoir une petite maison va au
rez-de-chaussée bastille comptant une
chance inouïe de pouvoir rester dans son
quartier de l'argonne à l'avenir
franchement il va être bien bien que mon
quartier moi je trouve que c'est une
bonne idée de détruire et refaire un
autre
voilà un autre un autre style de vie
[Musique]
faire tomber des tours pour remodeler
des quartiers rénovés des cités partout
en france
c'est l'ambition du programme national
de rénovation urbaine
[Musique]
comme ici à l'argonne au nord d'orléans
il faut rebondir après l'échec de ce que
les technocrates appelé successivement
les grands ensembles les quartiers
sensibles ou encore les cités de
banlieue ils ont été construits pour
répondre aux besoins de logement très
important après la guerre après la
deuxième guerre mondiale donc nécessité
par les nombreuses destructions de la
guerre mais aussi par une crise du
logement qui existait déjà depuis
longtemps
en fait on a dépensé énormément d'argent
pour les guerres coloniales la guerre
d'indochine guerre d'algérie et c'est
l'argent qui a été dépensé là c'est
autant qu'ils n'allaient pas pour le
logement on a commencé à construire en
masse à partir du milieu des années 1950
mais avec des surfaces très petit pour
faire des économies et puis avec des
méthodes de préfabrication
qui était pas tout à fait au point ce
qui fait qu'on a des logements petit mal
insonorisé avec des problèmes de
malfaçons c'est important l'illustration
parfaite de l'argonne ce quartier or les
années ou trois cartes des habitations
sont des logements sociaux
la métamorphose commence en 2004 mais
prend un tout autre tournant en 2008
avec le plan de rénovation urbaine aussi
appelé en rue dix huit ans plus tard la
donne at il véritablement changé de
visage c'est ce que nous avons voulu
savoir
ici on est au coeur presse mme ce qui
s'est passé parce que vous avez juste
sur ma gauche une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire vous avez sur ma
droite l'argonaute vous avez des petits
logements des ensembles de logements qui
ont été réhabilités on vient de voir
passer le tram et c'est assez symbolique
de ce qui s'est passé sur l'anru ans et
ça laisse présager de ce qui va se
passer sur eux sûrement rumeurs
car on n'imagine pas mais il y a neuf
ans ici il n'y avait ni le tramway ni ce
complexe sportif et culturel de 4000
mètres carrés
c'est une articulation de tout un acteur
qui sur un an
un quartier est fléché comme étant en
difficulté et/ou pour les habitants la
ville est un peu plus la vie est un peu
plus difficile qu'ailleurs on décide
pour parler trivialement de mettre le
paquet le paquet correspond à 216
millions d'euros pour les deux phases de
cette rénovation urbaine qui se
terminera en 2024
au total 6 135 logements sont rayés de
la carte et presque autant sont
réhabilités 436 on reconstruit la
plupart un petit pavillon - estampillé
cité un bouleversement des façades mais
pas seulement la vie des habitants est
également totalement bouleversé les
personnes qui sont sur dur logement
puisque leur appartement va être démoli
en fait ce sont des personnes qui y
vivent de toute façon pas bien la
situation dont il ya un accompagnement
des résidents de l'orléanais qui trouve
de toute façon une solution même si ça
prend du temps par exemple pour des
démolitions parfois on prenait un peu de
retard mais l'idée c'était vraiment de
reloger les personnes là où elle
souhaitait être et aussi d'avoir cet
accompagnement un petit peu humain
[Musique]
l'humain justement semble être mise à
rude épreuve parfois dans ses rues dans
ces immeubles des habitants vivent des
situations difficiles comme cette femme
elle habite depuis 35 ans dans son
appartement bientôt réduits en poussière
et la situation est tellement compliquée
avec le bailleur responsable du
relogement qu'elle n'a pas souhaité
dévoiler son visage
par peur de représailles français très
usés ici vous voyez même le parterre
comment qui fait mais c'est tout mais si
nombreux ce jeudi même si des mots ni
son moi qui m'ont donné un combat qu
après sim data sur la route séparant
millions - un appartement combat pour
moi j'ai un t5 hymne proposant des trois
mois j'aurais demandé un tic
il veut être abonné parce que ils
comptent comme si on était de 8 ans
rapide de révolte dans la comté et comme
si pour vous dire monsieur le logement
épouse avait dehors coup quand il me
parle et sedo mais alors comment
fonctionne l'attribution des logements
nous avons été nous renseigner chez les
principaux concernés
on propose en fonction de la composition
de la famille il faut comprendre qu'une
famille évolue dans sa vie ce qui est
normal mais aujourd'hui on peut avoir
des personnes qui sont seules dans un
type sain qui ne s'est pas adapté à leur
situation
c'est peut-être aussi l'occasion de
trouver le meilleur logement conçoit
d'adaptation donc on va proposer en
fonction de la famille peut-être un
thématique 2a type 3 avec des charges
peut être moins important on essaie de
trouver la meilleure situation le maire
réponse au choix la demande des
candidats mais c'est en moyenne trois
propositions qui sont faites pour chaque
candidat et si ça convient pas ces trois
propositions qu'est ce qui se passe
après pour continuent de fouiller une à
quatre de front et 1,5 et on se
décourage pas et on va jusqu'au bout
pour trouver la meilleure solution
en principe on y arrive
en principe c'est bien là le problème
notre anonyme elle a déjà refusé deux
appartements
le 3ème si je prends pas gueuler ciment
pour votre radio sinon il faut édifier
doucement le tribunal
tous les trucs comme ça jusqu'à utile
[Musique]
pour ne pas se retrouver à la rue ou
trop loin du quartier qu'ils occupent
depuis des dizaines d'années certains
habitants acceptent des logements tous
les petits quitte à se délester de
certains biens y en a qui j'étais malade
humains partout
[Musique]
car les places sont chères et seuls 86
logements détruits sont reconstruits
dans le quartier les 350 autres le sont
hors site c'est à dire sur les 22 autres
communes de la métropole orléanaise
c'est tout le but de la loi égalité
citoyenneté à la recherche de ce que
l'on appelle la mixité sociale est
souvent ça sert aussi à déplacer des
populations par exemple un tramway
arrive donc on apporte une amanite et
une qualité on change la vie et puis
effectivement on va déplacer les
populations les plus défavorisées pour
enfin sous prétexte de mixité sociale on
a tendance à faire augmenter les loyers
non ce genre de situation ce qui fait
que les plus pauvres ne peuvent pas se
loger ils partent dans un quartier qui
n'est pas rénové et ça crée une nouvelle
forme de ségrégation ont fini on éloigne
toujours les pauvres le plus loin
possible
le marché de l'immobilier à l'argonne
serait donc en train d'évoluer
de ce que nous avons constaté au sein de
nos agences le quartier de l'argonne a
connu un certain engouement ces derniers
temps ce qui n'était pas le cas depuis
des années ce que j'explique entre
autres mois par l'ensemble des travaux
qui ont été réalisés dans ce quartier
que ce soit au niveau de la métropole de
la région avec le futur lycée mais
également avec les promoteurs
immobiliers sur toute l'avenue des
droits de l'homme par exemple et
également parce que l'immobilier en
centre-ville d'orléans ayant pris un
essor important et les gens s'éloignent
un peu plus le prix de moyens était chez
nous lorsque nous avons constaté entre
1800 et 1900 euros du mètre carré et ces
dernières semaines lorsque nous
vendu nous ont passé la barre des 2000
euros c'est aussi pour des familles qui
pourraient être des familles nombreuses
ou avec des enfants la possibilité
d'acheter une maison qui ne pourrait pas
acheter sur d'autres secteurs d'orléans
c'est ce que l'on appelle la
gentrification un phénomène caractérisé
par l'arrivée de catégories sociales
plus favorisés ici les barres
d'immeubles ont laissé place à ces
pavillons sorti de terre en 2019 des
logements neufs proposés en location
accession un dispositif d'aidé à l'achat
progressif sans aucun apport personnel
une aubaine pour jean etienne pour
l'instant locataires on a eu de la
chance un on nous a proposé justement
d'avoir la possibilité d'acquérir une
maison avec ba voila c'est tous ces
avantages le jardin on a tous les
commerces de proximité qui sont vraiment
à même pas cinq minutes d'ici en voiture
en dehors de l'argonne impossible de
trouver dans son budget on a quand même
pas mal davantage
aussi rapport au système justement de
l'acquisition la location acquisition là
c'est que je vais pas le cacher c'est la
réalité c'est que on exonérer des impôts
pendant 15 ans et ça c'est pas
négligeable non plus donc avec tous ces
avantages là on n'a pas hésité en fait
t'as vraiment à fond c'est dans ce
projet là avec mon épouse mais même à
l'argonne y même à la bonne l'argonne
c'est je pense qu'il faut changer un
petit peu la façon dont de la mentalité
des gens auraient dit parce que quand on
dit l'argonne on pense tout de suite à
des quelques années en arrière 10 ans et
c'était un quartier difficile mais là
franchement depuis qu'on est là on n'a
jamais eu de souci le quartier des
cannes en quelques années l'argonne
s'est transformée et pas seulement dans
sa construction
l'insécurité semble être une lointaine
préoccupations le quartier s'est apaisée
et les associations y sont pour beaucoup
comme l'union pétanque argonnaise
symbole de mixité et de respect
[Musique]
l'objectif de la science aujourd'hui on
va travailler sur la maine de gagne et
la deuxième chose qu'on va travailler
c'est ce qu'on appelle la boule décisive
on est stigmatisée dans nos quartiers
cette image de délinquance qui nous
colle à la pause c'est pas du tout à la
hauteur de à la hauteur de ce que nous
on vit en réalité sur le terrain
certes on n'est pas dans le monde des
bisounours parce que sinon ce serait
trop facile mais il faut quand même
souligner toutes les initiatives qui
sont sur le quartier il ya très belle
initiative de jeunes qu'un v6 de famille
qui s'impliquent d'associations qui
donne vraiment beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'énergie au profit du quartier
à l'image des lois qui consacre son
temps aux autres depuis une dizaines
d'heures à sa droite tranquillement
cette génération là du coup à le
beaucoup moins touchés par ce discours
parce que il pourrait y vivent pas dans
un quartier sensible
c'était sans doute le cas pour les
anciennes générations mais aujourd'hui
les jeunes ne veulent plus en entendre
parler
commencer un quartier sensible
non vraiment pas du tout il est des gens
vraiment sympas ici et c'est pas du tout
les mois je condamne de l'argonne c'est
un quartier normal comme tous les écarts
s'il peut y avoir un peu délinquance
comme n'importe où faut juste et habite
et après on va voir que ce n'est pas un
capuchon c'est tout le monde est là pour
pour s'entraider sont à des problèmes
les habitants c'est tout c'est tous des
amours reflète que ce soit gène enfants
grands parents
tout le monde est gentil il est
peut-être là le message se rappeler les
valeurs d'égalité et de fraternité
au pays des libertés
à mi-parcours de son plan de
réhabilitation l'argonne et donc un
quartier en suspend ses habitants
veulent bien attendre attendre de
nouveaux logements de nouvelles
structures mais surtout attendre de
nouveaux emplois car construire des
bâtiments est une chose aider les
habitants à se reconstruire en est une
autre
[Musique]